all I want for Christmas is to take your
questions we cannot have a society in
which some dictator someplace can start
imposing censorship here in the United
States
imagine if producers and distributors
and others start engaging in
self-censorship
because they don't want to offend the
sensibilities of somebody's whose
sensibilities probably need to be
offended I think it says something
interesting about North Korea that they
decided to have the state and mount an
all-out assault on a movie studio
because of a satirical movie starring
Seth Rogen we will respond
proportionally and will respond in a
place and time and manner that we choose
with respect to Cuba this is still a
regime that represses its people and as
I said when I made the announcement I
don't anticipate overnight changes but
what I know deep in my bones is that if
you have done the same thing for 50
years and nothing's changed you should
try something different if you want a
different outcome issue and Keystone is
not American oil it is Canadian oil it
was never going to be the answer to
lowering gas prices because the oil that
would be piped through the Keystone
pipeline would go into the world market
and that's what determines oil prices
sometimes you know you've got a police
department that has gotten into bad
habits over a period of time and hasn't
maybe surfaced some hidden biases that
that we all carry around but if you
offer practical solutions I think people
want to fix these problems and now I'm
going to go on vacation Mele Kalikimaka
everybody